your fingers freeze up and get cold and
they feel like you've got a glove on
even when you don't it becomes almost
impossible to do some of the things you
could've do handling metal with bare
hands put it in your mouth and that
warms up is that a trick well I don't
really want to lose the nuts and washers
in the snow mouth but they're a bit
codes have been ripping bits of skills
my thing with them
cool put it up yeah heavy now serving it
hopefully this weather station will
become a part of helping us understand
what's going on here once we get a few
storms through hopefully it'll give us
some good data
it's a huge relief to be done sitting up
now we have our base camp for future
seasons and we figured out what we
needed to everything worked the way it
should have we showed that you know the
Ross Ice Shelf program works really
really well we have scientists from all
different disciplines all coming
together whatever we're gonna discover
it's going to be new it's gonna be
interesting so we can estates and stuff
here for the following seasons so we've
left 50 odd drums of fuel over there
next year will be coming straight back
out to this side and we'll have kind of
the basis of the camp already set up PSP
some of our food waste recycling in our
general waste will get rid of a fair bit
of that Scott bass they can only process
one of those people's every day so we'll
go home with 34 so we wanted to get as
many as we can back to Scott bass now to
start that process it's gonna take a
month to get rid of our peas from here
oh you don't need snacks how long is the
flight an hour yeah bears lick will take
away five of our people leaving us with
that little small crew to begin the
return journey
what is luxury accommodation space on
that feet
[Music]